all right it's for the jury
that's about to be read in the trial of
the former minneapolis police officer
you saw him standing there
derrick chauvin the judge has just
walked in asked everyone to stand as the
jury
is walking in there's the judge
all right let's listen in members of the
jury i understand you have a verdict
[Applause]
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr2012646
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1
44 p.m signed juror four person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter as to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april
2021 at 1 45 p.m
jury four person zero one nine members
of the jury i'm now going to ask you
individually if these are
your true and correct verdicts please
respond yes or no
juror number two are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number nine are these your true
and correct verdicts yes
juror number 19 are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number 27 are these your true and
correct verdicts
yes juror number 44
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 52 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 55 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 79 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 85
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes
juror number 89 is this your are these
your true and correct verdicts
juror number 91 are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number 92 are these your true and
correct verdicts
yes are these your verdicts will say one
so say you all
yes yes members of the jury i find that
uh
the verdicts as read reflect the will of
the jury and will be filed accordingly
i have to thank you on behalf of the
people of the state of minnesota for not
only jury service
but heavy duty jury service what i'm
going to ask you to do now is
to follow the deputy back into your
usual room and i will join you in a few
minutes to answer
questions and to advise you further so
all rise for the jury
and you you're watching dw news this is
our coverage of
the verdict reading of former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
he has been found
guilty on all three charges that include
second degree manslaughter
second degree murder and third degree
murder
the jury has just been led out of the
courtroom
and now let's listen in to what the
judge is saying to derrick show
we'll order a psi immediately returnable
in four weeks
and we will also have a briefing on
after you get the psi six weeks from now
and then eight weeks from now we will
have sentencing
we'll get you the exact dates uh
in a scheduling order is there a motion
on behalf of the state to have the court
uh revoke the defendant's bail and
remand him into custody
uh pending sentencing bail is revoked
bond is discharged
and the defendant is remanded to the
custody of the hennepin county sheriff
anything further all thank you
okay and there you have it the verdict
has been read guilty on all three counts
against derek chovin there he is he's
going to be taken away he will be
staying
in jail waiting and in eight weeks
the sentencing will be read for derrick
shoven guilty in the murder
of george floyd all right let's go
outside the courthouse there to our
correspondent
stefan simons he is covering this story
for us
stefan i can hear the horns behind you
that
there is approval of this verdict
yes absolutely celebratory honking here
galore right and left uh trucks
pickup trucks driving by black lives
matter uh
flags and so on uh this crowd here
which you can't really see in my
background now will swell
over the next few hours that is uh uh
for those people definitely a
a a proud and a very happy moment
i don't think that they really actually
thought that
he will be guilty on all three counts
given their experience with the
injustices they experienced in
the justice system whenever whenever a
white person or police
officer for that matter was standard
accused to do something wrong against a
black person now
but this is exactly what happened here
in this
uh trial that the blue wall the
so-called blue wall
this concouna of of silence of
supporting and helping and shielding
police officers
who were alleged to have something done
something wrong
that didn't just crack it crumbled the
entire minneapolis police department
leadership senior executive leadership
spoke against derek chauvin and what he
did and how he did this so
people here you can camera i can go over
there uh max if you would
show this so this is gonna be what it's
gonna be now for the next three hours
and this is just a small crowd that's
the beginning the infancy
of what we probably will see now for a
few hours
you know what we're seeing right now
these are people who are going to be
celebrating this verdict and
you know just a few minutes ago there
was a real concern that these people
were going to be
protesting if the verdict had gone the
other way
and that the protests could even become
violent i mean it is a completely
um different expectation than what a lot
of people had right
way to go about time yeah i mean i would
comment
common sense or i would at least uh
suggest that there is no reason now to
uh ransack
loot or or or or put buildings
in on fire or to seek
confrontations with police police law
enforcement
they will be present they are present
here yes this they trying to keep a low
profile and not be visible
those one thing is very clear those
people are very happy now they are
satisfied with this verdict or with the
with the verdicts
but um make no mistake um they're in
here for the long haul that is
george floyd justice for george floyd
that is justice for them but they want
to see now reform
not just one police officer one bad
apple
being charged and found guilty they want
to see
reform in the justice system when it
comes to how they are policed
who is their police you have the latest
case just from last week don't write
um not one police officer in this
district of minneapolis in brooklyn uh
center
actually lives there so they are from
outside there's no connection to the
to the community this is what those
people actually want this is what they
say they
need to actually stop uh anything like
what
derek chovin did and the george floyd
case symbolizes now
that's what they need to stop this for
good yeah it's almost as if we were
sitting on a ticking time bomb that has
been
disarmed is that an accurate way of
describing
the the tension in the united states
absolutely you nailed it
you nailed it you nailed it this is just
minneapolis uh think about la next week
30 years anniversary rodney king beating
and the
the resulting riots are there 30 years
um so this is an experience the black
community african-american community all
over
america is not just since george floyd i
don't want to belittle what happened to
george floyd god knows but
um again it is uh it is something which
it goes on for decades and
um i think really something broke here
something changed there's a paradigm
change here um
we talked about paradigm change last
year when we were uh
when when george floyd happened and then
after the
violence and and riots uh
here and everywhere in the world and in
the united states
so this will be an ongoing process in
the united states and yes
all over the united states law
enforcement authorities have prepared
for
a very very very different outcome of
this trial here
you